sempre que cansou e agora eu vou
procurar aqui um caminho protocol
parabéns paulo já que seattle estaremos
é é muito incerto mas anima tanto isso
eu sou empreendedor faça muito no que
pensar muitas pessoas inclusive eu mesmo
é que o gás está na frente
tanto eu também costumo dizer que são o
rio verde sonho pronto mas a estudar já
é um marco que me lembro como vocês
podem ver eu tenho um profissional e já
agora não sofreu nada não é
então ele tem que encontrar alguma coisa
mas felizmente não sofreu após virar
extremas do processo ao império que eu
tenho o cólon condição normal de amiga
que é que eu vou mostrando pouca voz e
vai calcular
a mexer nessas comissões em portugal a
29 anos atrás
não é fácil principalmente porque o país
e o maior nível estava envolvido não
estava preparado para meus filhos eu só
que eu tenho um pai uma mãe
extraordinária em que deu e 15 disseram
que eu ia fazer coisas que iria ser a
equipe que vence em 2011 só qual houve
uma mechinha tennessee com seis meses em
uma distensão
houve um problema grave inclusive ser
médica
o meu pai tinha 23 anos na altura a
minha mãe e eu estávamos mal
iremos morrer e uma webcam vida com meu
pai ele escolhe começa a procurar uma
funcionária porque eu não sou um sofá
enganou
mas tenho a minha voz foi muito dura
porque ainda tinha muitas dúvidas na
altura não é que eu sou do boto como é
que chávez é no momento tenho certeza
que no próximo ano vamos ser campeões
nacionais e é esse momento mudou minha
vida completa
não só porque tenho muita coisa é isso
mas eu nunca tinha visto alguém dizer
uma coisa eu não sabia que eu ia ganhar
tempo foi o que é certo é que ninguém
viu e depois a parte veio com senha
assim comecei a estudar o processo morin
16 a primeira era fumar em filosofia e
basicamente o pai começou a aplicar o
bom futebol e na energia do grupo e eu
sei como é e todos os que aqui eu sou eu
que digo com vários andares em nível
nacional é é a técnica responsável que
vai eu comecei e se chamava a sanção
mais ficar com medo não sabe dizer qual
é o problema que estava ter aqui não tem
muito tempo e se fosse comigo
era o erro é de facto e eu é possível eu
tenho muito medo e sim uma conversa que
não tem como eu treinava na altura
também faz tudo o que eu vi isso vai
estar me deixava o time inteiro porque é
o teu problema vai acontecer sempre tem
que primeiro me pegar e quando é quando
conseguia clix faca porque esse negócio
de vendas começaram depois é uma coisa
que é não lembrando o livro na viva num
mundo todo lado
nós para ter um sucesso numa determinada
área
temos que pensar concorda que isso não
estava combinado mas eu sei que eu ia
dizer que sim que tenta o fracasso é
muito importante para se obter sucesso
no final eu tenho eu tenho vou estar
dante era mesmo só uma canção não ficar
nona é eu sou ainda na faculdade santa
fox também pela tecnologia que realmente
está focada em criar soluções para
melhorar a vida do defensor e eu comecei
eu não comia foi não podia cumprir esta
missão que o pai na escola nós consegue
rever isso eu e meus colegas
o costa não é meu colega não é uma
personagem que eu gosto muito é um filme
que este ano então desde 2010 comigo é
até hoje
e só lá e folga onde quer que nós
começamos a tirar algo me lembre também
tem a ver com compromisso que vão tem
que ter quando forma alguma coisa é que
só o nosso momento áureo no website do
ano passado
agora é vamos focar num empresa que é um
estudo que nós é um grande exemplo ao
isolar no jogo vai ser lançado para o
playstation feriu pelo menos dentro é no
metal assim que pensa em lançar bso
cleveland e vai ver que mesmo nesta
empresa que eu estou a passar um
protocolo de investimento o que eu passo
as equipes um breve vídeo
sonhar não é tudo mas eu acho que a
senhora é premissa principal foi menor
conseguimos as coisas nós não tornar um
objetivo numa primeira está em seu
tópico para esse verão é que queremos
chegar
eu acho que você é premissa principal
para ter um sucesso é completamente e
comandamos nem navio
aqui estão algumas 2010 prevenções
também já tem com o mourinho foi chato
porque foi uma conversa muito e sempre é
bom destacar aqui minha família aqui os
que estão aqui em baixo guandu mais feio
meu irmão imagine o absurdo o cara que o
elenco você sa já não conta
foi muito importante a destacar é que eu
fui com muita gente lançava é além de
ter sido um grande méxico na sua área
que era funk eu tenho levo uma divisão
ou seja não vier praticamente nava
ari é desenvolver foi um jeito quando é
aplicar vá à distância que o
salvaguardar quando o futebol que eu não
via nada eu estava à sua frente está
cara que o pedro e não é por eu estar em
dia em frente mas é um bicho que você
todo disse ser melhores se lembrar que o
próprio ainda vai ter que voltar muitos
anos sabe
pensou sandy céu está lhe isto a venda é
foi falando ante a a pouco vamos agora
nós vamos começar é um estudo com um
túnel a nível profissional quer criar
uma nova empresa de 55 anos é pronto
amanhã é mais normal não é e o objeto de
mais sol eu quero muito ser pai é que
você é bom pai alguma quem me dera que
seja o senhor eu vai definir isto não tá
algumas dizem viver naquelas terras
silva
a viva não é primeiro preciso viver é
também para vencer e eu tenho uma tv
convencional e é como você é muito chato
isso aí
esta é a principal maneira de olha não
sei quando ele falou pra cima esta
mulher é o que diz o engenheiro
esta é uma das frases que mais uma
cowell e eu consegui mt também que na
minha vida
são 161 detonada quando mais cinco para
falar com decência até é até com o dia
tá nas coisas se vê que eu tenho que
fazer quando pensei em ceder o também
presidente da ale
assim não é não era o pedro paulo ainda
tem uma galera foi importante que a pec
é o venceu o que responder agora
o pedro é meu amigo é
é mas também feriu
o primeiro trio que os o léo e por isso
é que eu sei que não muito porque eu não
ia sair tudo sempre eu queria agora vou
falar não conheceu que chova amigos o
achou que era bonito e tal
e falando em futuro não é uma boa
pergunta internet é conhecia estava
especialmente fora quando quando conheci
a opção foi realmente boa
nós estávamos num evento do competições
lisboa
é muito barulho e pt pediram pra eu
falar com um empreendedor já tinha
falado com os meus a 15 já tinha muitas
questões no bolso e quando fui falar com
o bruno sempre quiseram uma posição para
ser um 30 trabalhista e quando cheguei
lá tive conversa de circunstância e tal
eu dei um cartão e guardar o cartão
nunca mais no meio do cartão
i é passado não lhe dei o meu cartão
como a linha dos outros também que
passavam os tempos e teve um cinema não
ter dado cartão
dom bruno a conhecemos não nani sair do
clube tal não sei que tenho um projeto
ele se aposentar então ele falou em
altura e estava pensando em conquistar e
e ao fim que de 5 10 20 chamadas a
caminhar que ele é hoje um grande campo
minado o pincel correu muito mal e os 35
anos são medidas idênticas ou muito mal
então ela insistiu fiz mais têm muito e
eu afetei liga e jô e e eu costumo dizer
que é o amor a quarta ou quinta vista em
volta deles é e ela apareceu aqui uma
equipa com um projeto com o pt pensava
com uma conversa bastante mais
estruturada e e sim mas a primeira foi
uma vez mais é a convenção de haia que o
meu amigo sumiu pronta e qual é a minha
característica uma pensão que nós
conhecemos pessoalmente porque há um
enorme e mesmo da nossa vivência tem
sido tão intensa que eu acho que o pedro
disse que viveu e vamos eles de um clube
eu queria me perguntado qual é que é a
minha maior característica como
empreendedor o que destaca enquanto
empreendedor e acho que sim acho que a
persistência é impressionante número no
qual pode chegar é ser um cara editais
o filme também pelo facto de o projecto
apresentou fox técnica é fazer o foco
técnico que tal empresa que não sei que
existem não é é um projeto que eu acho
que dadas as condicionantes do do setor
não vai funcionar
é tão somente 7 em relação a este
projecto e na altura disse que tendo em
conta as condicionantes que não que não
investir
não satisfeito com isso nenhuma cena
achou pessoa foi o pedro é um projeto
não gosta de falar consigo sequer
projeto é segunda nossa performance é
então adquirimos outra vez ele
apresentou desta vez de uma forma muito
mais estruturada ainda mais estruturada
é ea única condicionante que o que eu
lhe dei para continuarmos a falar sobre
isso foi o facto de
quero focar no mar uma coisa que ficasse
numa das duas empresas que agora acordar
- o estúdio
uma das coisas dos créditos virtuais que
também tem do ponto de vista de diâmetro
enquanto empreendedor é é muito
convencidos a esse gás bem o filho é que
as pessoas dão uma das coisas que
faltava muito foco e hoje dá né é
claramente está mais focado e isso é
muito importante neste momento enquanto
empreendedor é isso
enquanto pessoa aconteceu uma coisa que
não estava à espera eu eu somos o time
não gosto de viajar amigos novos ea
verdade é que hoje e é difícil não
considerar o bruno um dos meus amigos é
e mesmo que não vai entender o que eu
penso tudo isso tem um peso de 80 do
porto mas isso não basta
ainda falta meu deus eu creio também
observa que umas palavras não leva nesta
manhã
eu sabia que uma palavra valente
[Música]
eu eu tenho muito orgulho que esteja
nível zero isto é para comprar ela
sempre foi que eu pego estará lá
independentemente se o investimento não
viu e vasco mais querido do projeto em
conjunto da empresa 1001 porque eu vou
falar sobre tudo isso a companhia também
se apaixonar por fim foi que o metal e é
claro elas am enquanto o pensar como é
que eu sou santo
vai melhorar muito sangue é relação à
ciência e lançou benzema eu acho que a
mensagem que o clima cérebro que é muito
fácil desistir mas desisti não dá sinal
da globo vinhos elemento eu acho que
dizer o mesmo do continente está em meu
ouro ou maiô preto em press
eu acho que nós temos que estar viva
porque vivo é tão boa tá sempre foi o de
granel
acho que essa minha mãe que eu desisti
também é se fosse um dizem que é
possível e não é possível arrumar uma
maneira de cara e ver que não é possível
porque só quem vive feliz na minha vida
não anos com meu filho não é obrigado e
foi muito bom voltar com o